he's Joe Thomas Browns offensive tackle
busy man here but kind enough to join us
Joe let me start with that question we
just talked about would you be in favor
of a national law that prohibits contact
in football until you're 14 like at the
federal level
well state by you know every state has
to follow this I guess I've never
thought of it but I'm not in favor
generally of having the state making
laws about the games of football I think
maybe it could be a good idea if
individual groups of football teams get
together and decide that that's what's
best for our organization but I would
prefer that to come from a grassroots
level at the county level or within
different football organizations but
what if it was a county vote let's say
it's a local vote would you be okay with
something like that you're yeah yeah I'd
be okay with that I think flag football
is a great way to get a lot of different
people involved in the game of football
I think it gets a lot of girls involved
with football at a young age and I'd be
okay with waiting until you're 14 to
play tackle football all right a couple
things I wanted to talk to you about are
you recruiting Drew Brees right now I'm
not I am not currently recruiting him
I've met him a few times at the Pro
Bowls but I'm just making a point I
think with that the Browns aren't too
far off and there's a lot of good
quarterbacks that could become available
and and nobody really knows what's
inside Drew Brees his head and and what
he feels is best for him in the next
season
what if Drew said I'll play for the
Browns job but you got to be my left
tackle for the you know for a few more
years how about three years for each
would you sign them
can we give him my number do you want me
to join me to text him my number and
then you can have him call me I can
reach out to Drew no this isn't against
it you're not he's a free agent you're
allowed to reach out to him but I'm sure
you have his number yes me oh your video
host here I don't have a number I'm just
a lowly left tackle Fritzi would you
when we get ready to hang up would you
give Joe the number for Drew Brees sure
okay
and we'll try to help you out there now
it was a year ago when I asked the
following question to Joe Thomas of the
Cleveland Browns on what to do with that
number one overall pick here is Joe's
answer I would say you want a good
defense I think you need to get a pass
rusher I think you got to be careful
reaching for a quarterback at number one
because if they fail they don't help
your team at all whereas if you pick a
defensive lineman and maybe they don't
live up to the hype you can still find a
place to get them on the field and to
have an impact and we're a team that we
need guys that can come in and I can
start and they can contribute and I
think that's the risk of taking a
quarterback all right same question this
year Joe what do you do with that number
one overall pick great question I think
that was a pretty good take for me last
year I think you happy with Miles
Garrett I think he's proven to be quite
the good good player out there for us
yes actually I think it really depends
on what the Browns do in free agency and
clearly there's been a lot of
speculation that will trade for Alex
Smith I think if that happens you have
to take a quarterback either 1 or 4 but
if we go out and we do something like we
sign Kirk Cousins or one of those
younger quarterbacks then I don't think
you have to take a quarterback at number
one or number four and and you can sit
there and just take the best player
available at 1 and at 4 or you could
even trade back a couple spots and let
one of those quarterback teams skip you
draft a quarterback and then pick up an
extra first-round pick okay wait you
didn't say we went when you know at
first when you're talking about the
Browns you said the Browns not we in
what what they should do what are you
telling us Joe are you are you gonna be
with the Browns next year well here's
what I'm telling you I'm telling you I
got the number 2 podcast right now on
iTunes in the sports category called the
tomahawk show it has an unbiased media
member now that I'm in my podcast I try
to sometimes separate myself from being
just a homer
and boy from the Cleveland Browns
alright I like that and your your
partner with a Jayhawk the Andrew
Hawkins but they're both talk oh it's
pretty close I got some bad information
here
oh he's fired all right well it's
somebody named hawk and he came up with
a tomahawk so let it imagine if you had
a Jayhawk that would have been even
better you'd be too the number one
podcast there yes
I don't know Andrew Hawkins he's pretty
talented I'm pretty comfortable with my
co-host but I do love Andrew Raj Hawk as
well and maybe we can give him on our
show at some point I think he's got a
show on Sirius as well all right what if
the Browns decide to take a tackle let's
say number four yeah I mean I think it's
smart I think I'm 33 years old and no
matter what I decide to do in 2018 I
don't have too many more seasons left
under my belt so they got to start
thinking about the future of that
position whether it be this year or the
following year and I think that'd be a
very savvy move Johnny Manziel talking
about maybe going to the CFL I saw where
he's got some gear that he's trying to
sell and you tweeted out that maybe
you'd be interested in I think lost in
the sauce a hat that he has there do you
really want dearly Manziel gear swag I
do I'm a big fan of free swag and I love
dad jokes
I love the dad hats and that looks like
it would fit my personality perfectly do
you think he's gonna get a chance in the
CFL I don't see why he wouldn't I think
he's done a good job positioning himself
kind of putting out the message that
he's a changed person he's really
committed to football and he's ready to
kind of start towards the bottom there
and the CFL and work his way back into
the NFL and I think a team would be
smart to give an opportunity because he
definitely has the ability and it's just
him being able to show a team that he's
got the commitment level where it needs
to be to be an NFL quarterback could you
have given him advice when he first got
to Cleveland that would've helped him
and he would have listened I'm not sure
I mean he had a lot of good people
around him giving him advice and it
didn't seem to completely work and
I'm not sure I wonder how I would love
to ask him I think we're trying to get
him on our podcast and maybe have some
of those in-depth questions about what
could have been done differently so that
he did have a successful career in
Cleveland
the Browns lost to the Vikings in week 8
lost to the Jags in week 11 how good are
those defenses well I think they're the
two best defenses in the NFL and that's
not going out on a limb but I actually
think the Jags defense is probably a
little bit better I think their front
floor is a little bit more dominant and
a little bit more difficult to deal with
yeah when you look at you know coleus
Campbell I remember when people when
clays Campbell went to Jacksonville
people are like dude why would you go to
Jacksonville and you know disappear
there and then he's gonna be up for
Defensive Player of the Year no doubt
but the way I see the Jaguars from a few
years ago it's kind of where I see the
Browns right now we've got a ton of CAP
space we've got an owner that wants to
spend the money just like with the
Jaguars and I think we can put together
a great defense just like the Jaguars
did by spending the money and getting
those marquee guys like the Kalia
scandals are you saying Jaguars on
purpose like do you really believe that
that sounds pronounced Joe I mean that
Wisconsin education is that Jaguars or
Jaguars you said jagwire that's a Jaguar
I think it's Jaguar are you doing this
no I can't confuse you like I just we
had a problem with this yesterday we
needed to know how to pronounce Jaguar
and then you know the English say Jaguar
and then or Jaguar and then we heard
Jaguars so then when I thought you were
mocking me I thought you were you know
punking me Joe
so yes I've actually never heard this
discussion hey here's your podcast with
with you and a Jayhawk on your podcast
you guys
now you go you got one more year left on
your contract you yes one more year of
my contract up alright and you're
definitely playing have not made a
decision yet
what would be the tipping point of why
you would or why you wouldn't well I get
asked a lot what's going into my
decision and for me really it's just
going to come down to my overall health
do I feel like I'm healthy enough to
survive another NFL season towards the
end of my career I've had some back
injuries and some knee injuries that
have been really nagging and difficult
to handle and it's really gonna come
down to how those feel and if if I feel
like they're healthy enough to survive
another year why is it that we don't
talk about linemen getting concussions
it feels like it's quarterbacks skill
position players yeah I mean you guys
are getting hit every single play is it
because short you know the proximity of
you know those hits with the opposition
that maybe you don't get them as often
or am I being naive well I think the
linemen get the most overall hits to the
head out of any position but you don't
get as many of the big knockout punches
let's say a quarterback or receiver
would get where they're laying on the
field and they're unconscious typically
all the concussions that I've seen
between linemen you don't even really
see them on the ground they just come to
the sideline and they look a little bit
confused and they have a hard time
explaining what's going on and then they
get checked out for a concussion or even
the next day we had a player this year
that didn't feel anything during the day
nobody noticed it and then it was until
the next day that they noticed it but
it's rare because the distance between
us is so much shorter than for instance
the safety hitting a receiver where he's
getting a huge running start and coming
in with the knockout blow what did all
of this losing do to your sense of humor
hopefully it brought it out because I
think that's the only way to deal with
one win and two seasons but but a
defense to eat you up Joe that here you
more people talked about you being a
hall-of-famer and you've gone through
more losing seasons than probably any
hall-of-famer has well you hear people
talk about the best way to cope with
called situations and a lot of times
people say humor and I think that's sort
of been my coping mechanism over the
years would you trade in the hall of
fame for a Super Bowl win that's a tough
question I mean clearly Hall of Fame is
the pinnacle of personal accomplishment
in our sport and very few people get
there but the Super Bowl is the pinnacle
of the team sport and since I'm not in
the Hall of Fame right now I can easily
breeze as your starting quarterback
absolutely all right we'll work on that
and then you got the media career coming
up because it's rare to see an offensive
lineman in one of these media roles so
you know you're you're gonna make your
presence felt I'm gonna guess is that
what you want to do well it is unusual
but surprising I would say since
offensive linemen are historically the
best looking guys in the team so they're
the most natural to be in front of a
camera yelling at it I'd love for you to
post this one to him you and AJ hawk
could co-host the show if you wanted to
and Andrew Hawkins if you wanted to yes
I would love to do that I would love to
see you in the chair why I'd have to get
a bigger chair but I you and Andrew
Hawkins would be fun could you beat
there's one thing because there's one
thing your show needs more as you being
on vacation at I agree with you could
you beat up all for my dance could you
beat up the guys to have it at the same
time yes easily when's the last time you
were to fight Joe boy it's been a couple
years since I've been in a good training
camp site I would probably say yeah 2015
may be who wanted a PC you oh it's
always offensive indecent and defensive
lineman going at it I think you know
sometimes there's silly fights over you
know somebody hitting the guy after the
whistle or things like that usually just
because training camp gets long and hot
yeah but nobody's gonna like you're like
the star quarterback you're that you're
the best player on the team so nobody
they should give you like a red jersey
or something that nobody messes with
right well usually usually I'm not
practicing enough to actually get it any
fight
I'm using a guy the sideline running off
the sideline and pull people off the
pile give us where people can find your
podcast with Andrew Hawkins well the
great thing about our podcast is we're
nationwide we you can get us on iTunes
you can get us on the Google Play you
can get us on soundcloud anywhere you
find a podcast you'll get to tomahawk
show the tomahawk show with Andrew
Hawkins not a Jayhawk and enjoy Thomas
Joe enjoy the off season and we'll see
if we can help you with Drew Brees I
appreciate that thank you for having me
on night Joe Tom's he's fun I think he's
got a little bit of a future in the
media there after he goes to the Hall of
Fame he could do stand-up comedy I
really believe that you could get
somebody to write 10 minutes worth and
he could do some stand-up comedy there I
think he just did for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
[Music]